[Music]
thank you
[Music]
once you girl I'm always your girl
when I'm here when I'm there on a plane
and it's somewhere
where
you were staring down the course hoping
it would be one of ours
children and grandchildren writing your
cards but how long were you
waving for me
to make a left down on your street
[Music]
it's not if
darling it's when
there's always something
left on said
where you're
as green
with able
what was it that I forgot to
ask you
busy
[Music]
I love you right
I'll bet you're making
heaven
but it feels like tears and memories are
all
we have
once I knew it I was always I know it
all
to be busy to stressed out to take your
calls that I would always find you there
sitting in your TV chain
well time isn't about somewhere
the nurse said you
waiting for me
foreign
[Music]
what was it that I forgot today
busy
[Music]
I love you
here
[Music]
when this word and its people are
all
we have
[Music]
once you girl
girl I'm always your girl
[Music]
foreign
[Music]